Okay.
Guten Tag, so mein Name.
Ich bin hier als Assistenz in Tethik und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Gespräch führen.
Vor dem Gespräch würde ich ein paar Personen hier fragen.
Ist das für Sie in Ordnung?
Ja, natürlich.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Theo.
Theo.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen, bitte.
Ja.
Theo, Theo.
Und der Familienname?
Mhm.
Dombrowski.
Genau.
Okay.
Dombrowski.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 60 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Genau, ich bin schon 61, sehe ich gerade.
Am 1.07.61.
1.07.61.
Okay.
61 Jahre bin ich schon alt.
Ich werde 62 dieses Jahr.
Das ist mir recht.
Ich werde 61 dieses Jahr.
Stimmt schon, ne?
Wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin noch 74 kg.
74 kg.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1.83.
Dombrowski.
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ich habe seit langer Zeit schon so büchtige Bauchschmerzen.
Es wird immer schlimmer.
Insbesondere in den letzten 2-3 Wochen.
Haben sich die Schmerzen wirklich verschlechtert.
Dann habe ich gedacht,
jetzt muss ich doch mal damit zum Arzt gehen.
Das haben Sie sehr gut entschieden.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Das ist schon so vor einem Vierteljahr los.
Da habe ich immer gedacht, das geht auch wieder weg.
Ja, ich habe nicht akustisch gehört.
Vor einem Vierteljahr hat es angefangen.
Vierteljahr.
Also 3 Monate.
Sie haben gesagt,
dass die letzten 3 Wochen nicht schlimmer geworden sind.
Genau, da ist das richtig unangenehm geworden.
Deswegen habe ich gedacht,
ich kann das nicht mehr.
Ich habe gesagt,
ich kann das nicht mehr auf die lange Bank schieben.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Ich würde sagen langsam.
Dann haben sie sich gesteigert.
Und wo genau die Schmerzen sind?
Ja, die sind so oben im Bauch.
Ob am Brecht oder nicht.
Eigentlich so rund herum, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ja, ich habe gedacht,
ich stehe so rund herum, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ja, okay.
Ich strel die Schmerzen in andere Körperteile aus.
Nein, das ein ich nicht.
Nur so rings herum.
Rings herum.
Also einmal rund, wie so ein Gürtel quasi.
Ja, Gürtel, ja, okay.
Gibt es bestimmte Ausschlöser für die Schmerzen?
Ja, die sind immer da.
Wie oft?
Wie stark ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerz gewonnen?
Von 1 bis 10.
Also jetzt in letzter Zeit sind die wirklich heftig.
Da sind die bestimmt bei 7 oder 8.
Aber das klingt sehr stark.
Ja, das sind aber auch wirklich sehr heftige Schmerzen.
Soll ich Ihnen Schmerzmittel geben?
Oder halten Sie aus bis zum Ende?
Ja, das klingt sehr stark.
Aber halten Sie aus bis zum Ende?
Ja, das wird ja jetzt nicht so lange dauern.
Und ich habe die Schmerzen hier jetzt schon ein paar Wochen.
Dann kommt jetzt auch 20 Minuten auch nicht an.
Das wäre gut.
Haben Sie eine Schmerzmittel dagegen eingenommen?
Nein, ich habe mal versucht, ein Schnaps zu trinken.
Um die Schmerzen zu betäuben.
Das hat aber auch nicht wirklich geholfen.
Könnten Sie die Schmerz in Genoma beschreiben?
Sind Sie erhärtnig?
Oder...
Hori Kartig?
Also ich würde sagen, das sind so zielende Schmerzen.
Ja, und die Schmerzen alleine sind es ja nicht.
Sondern mir ist eigentlich auch so schlecht in letzter Zeit.
Und ja, ich habe keinen guten Appetit.
Und ja, tatsächlich habe ich auch keine Schmerzen.
Und ja, tatsächlich habe ich auch immer mal wieder so Durchfall.
Und nachts kann ich nicht gut schlafen, weil ich schwitzen muss.
Also ich bin irgendwie gar nicht mit mir zufrieden.
Okay.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie in Appetitlosigkeit haben.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Gewicht verlor?
Ja, doch.
Und Sie haben sich ordentlich abgenommen.
Wie viel Kilogramm?
Ja, ich bieg mich eigentlich so oft, aber ich habe...
Was war es, ich? So sechs Wochen oder so?
Hab ich acht Kilo abgenommen.
Acht Kilo.
Nee, es schmeckt mir zurzeit gar nicht.
Und Sie haben auch Durchfall.
Wie oft müssen Sie auf die Toilette gehen?
Bestimmt dreimal am Tag?
Manchmal mehr.
Wie sieht der Stuhl aus?
Ja, der ist irgendwie komisch hell.
Und konsistanz auch?
Na ja, also ein flüssiges Zeug.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben...
Sie schwitzen mehr als in der Nacht.
Und haben Sie auch Schlafprobleme?
Ja, normalerweise sonst eigentlich nicht.
Aber jetzt zurzeit wache ich nachts auf,
dass ich schweißgebadet bin.
Und da muss ich mir einen anderen Schlafanzug anziehen.
Und das kenne ich eigentlich sonst gar nicht.
Waren Sie deswegen beim anderen Arzt?
Nee, ich habe immer gedacht, das geht von alleine wieder weg.
Wieder weg, ja.
Deswegen war ich jetzt noch nicht beim Arzt.
Aber jetzt, als es so schlimm wurde, habe ich gedacht, ich komme zu Ihnen.
Ja, das haben Sie sehr gut entschieden.
Und ist Ihnen über Herr Donorski?
Ja, das ist glaube ich auch ein Grund,
weil ich nicht so richtig Essen mag.
Weil ich immer das Gefühl habe, dass mir so ein bisschen schlecht ist.
Ja, okay.
Muss er Sie auch erbrechen?
Nee, übergeben musste ich mich noch nicht.
Ich habe das Gefühl, das wäre das so kurz davor.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie viel wahr?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Ich habe aber auch ehrlich gesagt nicht gemessen.
Aber vielleicht Schüttofrost?
Nee, das wäre mir ja aufgefallen.
Das habe ich nicht gehabt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schüttogang?
Ja, eigentlich nicht.
Aber was mir jetzt aufgefallen ist,
dass der Urin so ein bisschen eine andere Farbe hat als sonst.
Wie sieht der Urinage?
Ja, der ist so dunkel.
Dunkel?
Trinken Sie Genöckwasser?
Wasser trinke ich eher nicht.
Wenn dann trinke ich eigentlich lieber Bier.
Aber manchmal trinke ich auch Sprudel
oder sowas Cola.
Aber ich denke schon, dass ich gar nicht so wenig trinke.
Ich bin ja den ganzen Tag zu Hause.
Dann hat man Zeit zum trinken.
Sind Ihnen Burus chimatsin,
Herzrasen oder Luftnot aufgefallen?
Nee, das habe ich noch nicht bemerkt.
Nein.
Danke.
Ich habe noch nicht bemerkt.
Sind Sie gegen Corona geimpft?
Ja, aber erst zweimal.
Zwei Mal.
Noch nicht beimpft.
Ich konnte mich sehr spät entscheiden, das zu machen.
Ja, okay.
Ich würde antworten über Ihre Vorgeschichte.
Leider Sie ein kronischer Erklang haben.
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Sie sind kein gesund.
Deswegen nervt mich das auch so, dass ich so schlecht drauf bin.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Schon lange her.
Das ist ein junger Mann, 25.
Da habe ich einen Autounfall gehabt.
Da ist es eine Beinung.
Ich habe mich schon lange nicht bemerkt.
Da ist es eine Bein gebrochen gewesen.
Das musste operativ versorgt werden.
Da habe ich eine kurze Zeit im Krankenhaus gelegen.
Ist diese Operation komplikationlos verlaufen?
Das ist alles glatt gelaufen.
Ja.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf nicht die Kommentare ein?
Nein.
Haben Sie alle eine Bein gebrochen?
Haben Sie allergie ein Vertrinklichkeits?
Nein.
Ich glaube, ich kann alles vertragen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie gerne Bier trinken.
Trinken Sie...
Wie viel trinken Sie Alkohol?
3-4 Flaschen Bier am Tag trinke ich schon.
Hin und wieder.
Wenn es mal passt, auch noch ein Schnaps dazu.
Schnaps.
Wie viel Schnaps?
Das kommt immer auf die Gelegenheit an.
Wenn man das Gefühl hat, dass das Essen besser rutschen kann.
Wenn man mal mit jemandem feiert.
Wenn man mal jemanden trifft, mit dem man sich lange nicht getroffen hat.
Dann trinkt man auch einen Schnaps.
Gelegant nicht trinken Sie.
Ja, okay.
So seitlich Schnaps.
Brauchen Sie...
Ja, ich brauche ordentlich.
Wie viel Zigaretten am Tag?
Eine knappe Packung brauche ich bestimmt am Tag.
Aber auch schon seit ich 18 bin.
Seit 18 bin.
Okay.
Und die nächste Frage ist eine Routine Frage.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nee, mit so was kenn ich mir nicht aus.
Erdom Roski, sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Ja, meine Mutter ist gesund.
Aber mein Vater, der ist tatsächlich an Darmkrebs gestorben.
Im Waldschirm, alter?
Oh, da war der...
65 oder so.
65.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Nee, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin geschieben.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, eine Tochter habe ich, aber die lebt bei Ihrer Mutter.
Ist Ihre Tochter gesund?
Ja.
Was macht Drucker?
Ja, in der Zeitung.
Ja, natürlich.
Dass man da die Maschinen bedient.
Das läuft heute alles autark.
Ja, ich bin da schon seit 5 Jahren arbeitslos.
Ich habe mein Lebtag als Drucker gearbeitet.
Das wird halt nicht mehr gebraucht.
Dann habe ich nicht wieder eine Stelle gefunden.
Das läuft heute alles automatisch.
Da braucht man keine Profis mehr.
Herr Dombroski, ich habe alle wichtigste Informationen bekommen.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Oder gibt es etwas, das Sie mir sagen möchten?
Ja, also Fragen habe ich natürlich schon.
Wie es jetzt weitergeht und was das sein kann.
Was mir da solche Beschwerden macht.
Natürlich habe ich auch...
ein bisschen Angst wegen meines Vaters.
Ob ich vielleicht auch Darmkrebs habe.
Das sind so die Sachen, die mir in letzter Zeit
ein bisschen im Kopf rumgehen.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Sie haben trarge Geschichte hinter sich.
Und deswegen haben Sie gesagt,
dass Sie bei der Zeitung,
dass Sie die Zeitung haben,
dass Sie wahrscheinlich eine Krebserkrankung haben.
Aber ja,
jetzt Krebs ist nicht 100% einzuschliessen.
Aber ich vermute, dass Sie haben...
Sie haben...
eine Speicheldröseentzündung.
Was habe ich?
Eine Speicheldrösenentzündung.
Ja.
Und das kann man dagegen tun?
Ja, jetzt, das bleibt nur ein Scherdach.
So ernst möchte ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Danach wird bei Ihnen Ultraschard durchgeführt.
Dann...
Ich brauche auch Labortperimeter.
Deswegen...
Ich werde Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Und gegebenenfalls...
Ja, wird bei Ihnen Computer-Tomografie durchgeführt.
Was ist das?
Das ist eine Bildgebene-Verfahren.
Ein Bildgebendes-Verfahren, ja.
Was kann man da sehen?
Ja, Ihre Bau als Schnittbild können wir sehen.
Sie liegen auf einem Tisch und gibt es eine Röhre.
Und mit Hilfe von Schittrallen können wir viele Schnittbilder
auf einem Monitor sehen und beurteilen.
Ich glaube, das habe ich schon mal gehört,
dass das so ist, als ob man in Scheiben geschnitten wird.
Man kann da reingucken.
Ja, ja.
Und was kann man dann sehen?
Man kann vielleicht eine Entzündung im Bauschweißeldrüste
oder eine Raunförderung im Bauschweißeldrüste
oder eine Schittein im Bauschweißeldrüste.
Das kann ich mir dann vorstellen.
Gut.
Dann habe ich jetzt sonst erst mal keine Fragen mehr.
Ja.
Gut.
Und?
Das ist noch Fragen.
Wie hast du dich gefühlt?
Ja.
Guten Tag.
Hallo.
Das ist gut, eine gute Annäquete.
Ich denke.
Danke.
Aber ich muss ich teils fragen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Aber welche Fragen?
Ich weiß nicht.
Sind Sie gelb?
Ja, oder?
Ich habe eine gelbe Hautfarbe aufgefallen.
Aber genau genommen sieht man,
dass wenn der Patient zur Tür reinkommt.
Ja.
Das ist der insbesondere,
wenn die Augen aukepfelgelb sind.
Und wenn jemand so richtig schön gelb ist,
dann springt ein das ja färmlich an.
Das sieht man ja färmlich auf der Straße,
wenn jemand vorbeidungst.
Ja.
Aber man kann tatsächlich fragen,
ist Ihnen aufgefallen,
dass Ihre Augen sich verfärben
oder das Weiße in den Augen sich verfärbt?
Dieser Mensch ist ja nun auch eher,
ja, vielleicht nicht so der Akademiker
oder so den man jetzt mit Fachbegriffen befragen kann,
sondern der will,
dass er eher einfach gefragt hat.
Aber das könnte man tatsächlich fragen,
ist Ihnen das aufgefallen
oder setzen Sie doch mal Ihre Brille ab,
dass ich mal Ihre Augen angucken kann.
Ja, zum Beispiel, ja.
Und gibt es sonst noch weitere Fragen?
Und eine,
nur differenzial Diagnost
Bluttransition erhalten oder...
Ah ja, okay.
Das wäre natürlich nicht ganz ausgeschlossen
vor 25 Jahren bei dem Unfall.
Ja.
Aber das ist natürlich...
Das ist eine Idee, ja.
Ja, wäre ich jetzt tatsächlich auch nicht draufgekommen.
Aber da der ja gesagt hat,
er hat praktisch sonst keine OP gehabt
und vor 25 Jahren,
ich kann das dann immer noch,
ja, ist nicht auszuschließen,
dass er da in dem Fall tatsächlich
eine Transition bekommen hat.
Das finde ich ein spannender Hinweis, ja, sehr gut.
Vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank auch.
Ja, so, weiter machen
oder gibt es doch irgendwelche anderen Anregungen, Ideen, Fragen?
Nee, alle sind begeistert.
Gut, dann machen wir weiter, Lisa.
Ja, guten Tag.
Ich bin der Sonmasist, mein Name,
der überrascht ist.
Und...
Haben Patienten gesehen, habe ich mitbekommen?
Ja, aber...
vor dem ich meine Patienten vorstelle,
möchte ich etwas wichtiges mitteilen.
Ich habe auf dem Labor angerufen,
einen Anruf bekommen,
um das zu machen.
Frau Clemens hat einen Trombosit-Zellen,
1.250.000 Trombosit-Zellen,
pro Mikroliter.
Ja, haben Sie das schon weitergegeben
an die zuständige Kolleginnen?
Ja, ja.
Ja, dann ist das gut. Die kümmert sich dann schon drum.
Ja, ja, ja.
Dann erzählen Sie mal, wen Sie gesehen haben.
Ja, okay.
Es handelt sich um.
Herr Thelodom Ruski.
Er ist 60 Jahre alt.
Er ist erst des 1791 geboren.
Er ist 70 Kilogramm und 1 Meter 80.
Herr Thelodom Ruski hat bei uns heute
wegen seit vier Monaten
5.00 Uhr, ob er bei Schmerz vorgestellt hat.
Er hat sich vorgestellt, ja.
Und diese Schmerzen
sind seit zwei, drei Wochen immer schlimmer geworden.
Wie beschreibt er die Schmerzen?
Sie beschrieb die Schmerzen, als sie handelten.
Die Patienten, der Patient, der Mann, der Patient,
gappen, dass diese Schmerzen Oberbau lokalisiert und guter für mich.
Genau, okay, ja.
Warum stellte sich es jetzt vor?
Ja, die Patienten hat gezackt, dass sie immer diese Schmerzen
Also er hat gedacht, die Schmerzen gehen von alleine wieder weg und als es schlimmer geworden ist, hat er sich dann wieder auf die Schmerzen getroffen.
Und dann hat er sich dann wieder auf die Schmerzen getroffen.
Ja, also er hat gedacht, die Schmerzen gehen von alleine wieder weg und als es schlimmer geworden ist, hat er sich dann entschieden doch zum Arzt zu gehen.
Ja, ja.
Gut, alles klar.
Ja, was hat er denn noch sonst so an Nebensymptomen?
Nebensymptomen, sie sei über, ohne Erdbecher.
Und sie klafft über ihn ab.
Liebe Nisa, es ist immer noch ein Mann.
Ja, ich.
Ja, sie sind trau und deswegen ist es schwierig.
Ja, ja, ja.
Aber es ist keo.
Ja.
Er klafft über Inappetanz und
die Vegetative einer Amnesie ist unauffällig bis auf Gewicht, einen Gewichtverlust
von 8 kg innerhalb von 6 Wochen.
Und zusätzlich habe er die Röhre und er muss 3 Mal auf die Toilette gehen.
Wegen Stuhlgaben, wegen Durchfall.
Ja, und der Stuhl sieht heil aus.
Und der Urin Farbe sieht heil aus dunker Farbe.
Der Urin ist dunkelverfärbt.
Ja, also der Stuhl ist heil, der Urin dunkel.
Und gibt er etwas, sagt er etwas zu Fieber,
die Nachtweiß, die Stuhlfrost?
Die Nachtfrage, Fieber, Stuhlfrost und Luftmord, Brustschmerzen,
wurden verneint.
Die Vorgeschichte ist unauffällig,
er sei wegen Beifraktur operiert worden vor 520 Jahren,
wegen einem Autounfall.
Bei Zustand nach Autounfall, ja, okay.
Er trinkt 3-4 Flaschen Bier und zusätzlich geregeltes Schnaps.
Jeden Tag 3-4 Flaschen Bier?
Ja, jeden Tag.
Okay.
Er raucht 20 Zigaretten pro Tag seit er 18 bin.
Er ist.
Und die Familienanamnese.
Das sind also gut 40 Packers, ne?
Ja, 40 Packers.
Und die Familienanamnese fangen sich bei dem Vater,
mit 5 von 70, färsch zorgen.
Und dem Kulonkatinon?
Ja, er sei gestiegen, habe eine Tochter
und seit 5 Jahren sei er arbeitlos.
Ja.
Okay.
Was ist denn jetzt Ihre Diagnose?
Ja, meine Verdachtdiagnose ist chronische Packers.
Gut.
Was wäre differential Diagnostisch noch möglich?
Ja, differential Diagnostisch, denke ich,
an Pancreas Karstenau und vielleicht Hinterwand,
Infaptus, Meokatinfaptus.
Ja, ja, warum nicht, ja, genau.
Und das könnte noch sein.
Und Ulkustventilö könnte sein.
Und Kolelitis, ja, das ist viel.
Genau, dass der vielleicht Steine hat, genau.
Ja, die Schmerzen ist nicht typisch, aber vielleicht.
Ja, gut, okay.
Was machen Sie denn jetzt diagnostisch mit dem?
Ja, so als würde ich körperlich untersuchen.
Ja.
Ich guck, achten Sie da besonders?
Ja, ob die Patienten eine Fertilierung
von der Herzuchtung habe.
Und bei Oskulation gucke ich, ob die Patienten
wie die Darngeräusche ist.
Wie die, was?
Darngeräusche.
Und ich würde auch abtesten, ob die Patienten
Abwehrspannung, Druckschmerzen habe.
Und ja, ich würde auch gucken, ob die Patienten
Kulanszeichen habe, vielleicht,
weil meiner Schardachdiagnose ist.
Ja.
Noch mal, was soll sie haben?
Kulanszeichen.
Noch mal.
Oder Kulanszeichen.
Nicht, kann ich nicht.
Ich kann das Wort, ich kann das Wort, das ist gerade nicht,
nicht einordnen.
Ja, schuldigung.
Ich muss wieder gucken, wie kann man sagen,
oder vielleicht eine Kollegin kann herrschen.
Oder Kulanszeichen.
Ja, Kulanszeichen.
Oder Graetunnelzeichen.
Ja, ja.
Okay, ja, sorry, das ist jetzt was, was ich nicht kenne.
Ja, alles klar.
Gut, also ein Sowiesozeichen, ja, alles gut.
Ja, gut.
Und wie auslädt sich das?
Können Sie das mal beschreiben?
Ja.
Dann kann man beide Seiten eine Schärftrendung,
Schärftrendung, kann man
Perum um den Nabe,
oder kann man im Leisten
diese Seiten, das Farbe ist
ein bisschen blau oder rote Farbe
und kann man einfach beurteilen.
Ja, okay, danke.
Wieder was dazu gelernt, ja.
Was machen Sie für Laboruntersuchung?
Ja, ich würde
kleines Brutbild, Elektrolyden,
Amylase, Lipase, Rate,
H1,
A,
Hb1,
Langzeitig,
Glucose, Nüttanglucose,
Neermarte, Lebevarte,
Cholestaseparameter,
und
Lebevarte,
Cholestasevarte,
Agenda,
Alpinanzosthetase,
und ich würde auch im Schutur
Archeelastase
kuchen.
Sehr gut, okay.
Gutthetase für chronische
Ankreotitis.
Wenn du sowieso alle paar Stunden zur Toilette musst,
dann wird der ja auch eine Stuhlprobe abgeben können.
Nehmen Sie den Patienten
stationär auf?
Ja, ich würde stationär aufnehmen.
Ich möchte auch
Sonografie abdummern durchführen.
Auf alle Fälle, ja, okay.
Was erwarten Sie da?
Kann man nichts sagen, aber kann man auch
irgendwärts
Verkalkung im
Pankreas oder
Bauschweißer,
oder
im Galangengel oder
Speiserdruhsegengel
irgendwärtskongrement.
Man kann auf die Art und Weise ausschließen.
Genauso wie man wahrscheinlich
ja auch in Tumor
erkennen könnte, wenn der einer wäre.
Was wir ja mal nicht hoffen für den Patienten.
Dann auch für dich,
Sonografie durchführen.
ELCP ist sehr wichtig
in diesen Patienten.
Woher steht ELCP?
Endoscopy, Retrograde,
Colangiopancreaticography.
Wie aus dem Pistole geschossen.
Was machen wir den Stationär mit den Patienten?
Ja,
Alkoholkarans ist sehr wichtig
und Nahrungkarans,
bis sie diagnostiert
wurden.
Und Flüssigkeit zuvor,
ja, beim
auffälliges, eine elektrolyde
Mangel, muss man elektrolyde
Substitution machen.
Und vielleicht beim
Exokrina oder endokrine
Pankreatische Enzymmangel
sehr gut.
Enzymelsatztherapie,
sehr schön, wunderbar.
Und bei Entsündung muss man
Antibiotische Therapie
so schinaubimöglich entrich einhalten.
Und was machen wir mit den Schmerzen?
Ja,
kann man,
deswegen kann man opioid
geben, aber nicht alle opioide.
Ich glaube, Tilly-Din
kann man geben.
Und gucken wir mal, wie er da darauf reagiert.
Ja, ja, gut.
Ja,
dann würde ich sagen,
gucken Sie doch mal direkt nach dem Patienten, ich bin gespannt, was die
Ich bin gespannt, was Sie nachher zu erzählen haben.
Jetzt habe ich aber noch eine Frage.
Eigentlich nur eine Frage.
Nur eine Zusatzfrage, die in dem Zusammenhang gestellt worden ist
oder bei diesen Patienten gestellt worden ist.
So als ja aus dem hohen Bauchhaus.
Was versteht man unter einer Reha?
Ja, Reha ist eine Folgezerepil.
Nach dem Krankenhaus oder nach dem Erkrankung
für Wiederstellung der Patienten Physische oder Physische Wiederstellung
kann man in einer Reha-Klinik schicken.
Woher steht denn die Abkürzung Reha?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Rehabilitätssüderung.
Rehabilitation.
Ganz einfach.
Super einfach.
Wiederherstellung und eben auch Sozial- und Arbeitsleben.
Wieder Einpilierung und Arbeitsleben.
Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt.
Ganz genau.
Im Anschluss an Trauma, Erkrankung oder OP.
Das sind die Punkte.
Das wäre vielleicht noch eine interessante Frage gewesen.
Ob der seinerzeit vor 25 Jahren nach seiner Beinfraktur
gleich wieder arbeiten konnte oder ob der eine Reha hatte.
Aber wir kennen das heute eigentlich überwiegend so bei älteren Leuten.
Dass die Reha kriegen nach Hüftapp oder Knietapp oder so.
Oder eben auch nach anderen großen OP-Präs.
Dass die wieder aktiv werden.
Wobei tatsächlich, wenn man zu alt ist,
kriegt man tatsächlich in Deutschland auch keine Reha mehr.
Dann machen die noch so ein bisschen eine Anschluss-Heilbehandlung.
Dass man so gerade eben wieder krabbeln kann.
Aber eine richtige Reha ist das eben nicht mehr.
Gut.
Ja.
Also ich bin sehr zufrieden als Oberärztin.
Ich bin auch als Patient der zufrieden.
Ja, das ist nicht gut.
Aber das ist ja in der echten Situation.
Du kriegst ja eindeutig ein Mann oder eine Frau als Patientin.
Ich müsste mir jetzt Hut auf der Sonntbad ankleben.
Da wird man erkennen.
Eine Sache ist mir allerdings aufgefallen.
Ich muss sich unbedingt noch mal los werden.
Das sagen zwar alle so, aber ich finde das wirklich schräg.
Wenn man sagt, dieser Patient hat eine unauffällige vegetative Anamnese.
Ne.
Also wenn drei Faktoren nicht stimmen,
dann ist die vegetative Anamnese nicht unauffällig.
Ja, richtig.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist auffällig in Bezug auf.
Übelkeit, Nachtschweiß und Durchfall, Erscheinung und Gewichtverlust
und Appetitlosigkeit.
Also dieser Mann ist tatsächlich vegetativ ja nicht unauffällig.
Und dann sie wieder hoch.
Also die vegetative Anamnese ist auffällig aufgerutscht.
Ja oder in Bezug auf.
In Bezug auf ja.
Ja.
Oder bei Erfragender vegetative Anamnese fällt auf.
Und dann kann man die Sachen nennen.
Aber darf man unauffällig zu sprechen,
das trifft es ja nun wirklich nicht so richtig.
Was soll noch passieren, damit man aufhängt.
Ja, aber das ist tatsächlich,
ist mir schon in ganz ganz ganz vielen Gesprächen hier aufgefallen.
Nur jetzt im Augenblick habe ich gerade gedacht,
das muss ich mal wieder sagen.
Ich habe das auch irgendwann vor langer Zeit schon mal gesagt.
Aber ja, vielleicht das noch so als Aspekt für übermorgen.
Wer weiß, was du bekommst.
Vielleicht kriegst du Herrn der Herrn Sabrowski tatsächlich.
Ja, vielleicht.
Ja.
Gut.
Ja, hat doch irgendjemand eine Ergänzung,
irgendwas dazu zu sagen für die Liebenießer.
Darf ich etwas sagen?
Immer.
Ja, man sollte hier auf jeden Fall den Krebs ausschließen,
weil ihr Vater wegen des Krebs gestorben ist
und der Patient in Lester-Seit-Field abgenommen hat.
Deswegen sollte man wahrscheinlich Karstöne-Embryonisch antigen
und biopsy.
Ah, okay.
Das finde ich noch schön.
Ja, sie ist alt und rauf viel.
Ja, ja.
Alter, hör mal, 61 Jahre.
Ist Karstöne-Embryonisch antigen genug oder manus real?
Ist Karstöne-Embryonisch antigen, ich denke,
sollte man auch, ja, biopsy und kolonoskopi, ja, ich denke,
das ist gut.
Ah, dass man, dass man auch noch den Kolon, ja, das stimmt natürlich.
Das ist auch ein interessanter Gedanke.
Ja, nach dem Motto, nicht nur eine,
sondern zwei Baustellen sozusagen.
Ja, genau.
Der Patient hat gestern auch, dass er kein Fieber bemülkt hat.
Ja.
Den Krebs ausschließen, ja.
Ja, richtig servis.
Ja, guck mal.
Aber ich habe gedacht, wenn man im Kleines Bloodbund
einen Anämise und, ja, aber man muss ausschließen, ja.
Sie haben recht, ja.
Das ist ein guter Tipp für mich.
Ich finde, das ist echt ein guter Hinweis, ne?
Ja, ja.
Der kann ja tatsächlich außer seiner Pankreatitis,
die er jetzt im Augenblick hat,
kann der ja noch schleichend sein Uhrzeit in einem Darmtumor haben.
Das klingt gar nicht so, so unwahrscheinlich.
Haben wir noch irgendein Hinweis, eine Idee?
Ja, eine Idee.
Das ist ein guter Hinweis.
Ich glaube, es ist eine gute Idee.
Aber es ist guter Hinweis.
Ich denke, es gibt eine eine wie gute Prankreatitis.
Und sehr wichtig,
weil dieser Patient hat viele Jahre gelacht.
und seit zwei, drei Wochen verschlägt und eine Schmerzintestät-Liga bei sieben bis acht.
Und ich denke, akute Schub von Chronischen Pankratitis möglich.
Ja, ich habe auch gedacht. Aber ja, wegen dieser Theatöre im Schuttur und dunkler Urin,
muss man Chronische Pankratitis sagen oder einen akuten Schub?
Ja, richtig. Die Patientin Chronische Pankratitis, aber alle Symptome, eine akute Schub.
Im Akute erwarten wir auch Fieber im Akuten Schub?
Ja, keine Fieber.
Akute ist eine Form akutes Abdomen.
Ja, okay. Also ich denke auch, diese Fieber oder nicht Fieber Aussage,
ist bei diesem Patienten auch nicht so richtig ernst zu nehmen.
Der hat ja bisher ziemlich viel ignoriert und ist ja auch erst zu einem relativ späten Zeitpunkt überhaupt zum Arzt gekommen.
Und wenn der gar nicht Fieber gemessen hat, dann weiß er ja wahrscheinlich auch nicht wirklich, ob er Fieber hat.
Und das könnte man ja auf alle Fälle nochmal nachkontrollieren.
Das ist ja eines der Ersten.
Ja, ich habe noch eine Frage.
Muss man in diesem Patienten plötzlich RCP durchführen oder muss man warten?
Oh, das müssen die Fachleute wissen.
Ja, ich habe keine Erfahrung.
Wenn die Patienten akute Schub oder akute Exzellenzation einer Konjunktur,
RCP ist nicht, ja, danach verlauskontrolle gibt,
aber eine Komputer-Tomografie mit Kontrastmittel oder Magnet-Resonance-Tomografie mit Kontrastmittel,
BESA, und Ultrasynografie, BESA,
aber ERCP, wenn die Patienten eine Koleidokolitialis und denken,
dann kann die ERCP möglich, aber erst einmal CT-Komputer, CT-Tomografie und Ultrasynografie.
Oder MRCP ist ja auch sehr gekraftig in diesem Patienten?
Aber MRCP ist sehr gut, aber keine MRCP-Indo-Schrank-Tipi,
die jetzt schnell machen, aber MRCP nicht schnell machen.
Da bin ich jetzt tatsächlich raus aus der Diskussion, weil ich zu wenig Ahnung von der Materie habe.
Da kommt eine Info, kann jederzeit durchgeführt werden.
Vielen Dank für alle, die sich beteiligen.
Ja, das bleibt uns für heute. Ich glaube, wir hören jetzt auch für heute Abend.
Wir machen dich nicht noch kribbeliger.